c'est un personnage qui a été victime
d'une injustice qui était en prison -
rim qui n'a pas fait il revient dans la
ville pour d'abord trouver qui a fait le
gris mais qu'il a fait renvoyer en
prison voilà la ville dans laquelle jean
paul belmondo vient retrouver son passé
c'est lille le film adapté par michel
audiard d'un roman de philip siens
marceau a pour titre le corps de mon
ennemi
il est signé henri verneuil et sortira
au milieu du mois d'octobre les
extérieurs ont été tournées au mois de
mai à lille roubaix et tourcoing
outre jean paul belmondo marie france
pisier daniel ivernel et bernard blier
font partie de la distribution
dans une oeuvre qui n'est peut-être pas
dans la tradition des films réalisés par
henri verneuil de l'action il y en aura
certes mais moins que d'habitude ce
n'est pas infini d'action mais vous
savez les fils d'henri verneuil il y en
a eu avec action et y en a eu 100
actions un singe en hiver avec le même
belmondo était 1 800 actions le casse et
le clan des siciliens ou peur sur la
ville était un film avec l'action celui
là nous avons toujours le support qui
est en suspens pendant tout le ville
mais on ne tire pas de coups de revolver
il faut de temps en temps laissez
reposer les arbres il y a pas si
longtemps qu'on a vu jean paul belmondo
dans un film psychologique c'est plutôt
une d'action en ce moment oui oui mais
si mbia l'action mais là j'en ai fait un
petit peu trop disons je pars faire
cataloguer que dans l'action je reviens
un peu à des films je faisais au début
de ma carrière
nous c'est un choix ou bien il se trouve
dans le vernet vous a proposé
actuellement ce scénario société darwin
en jeu on se réveille pas le matin en se
disant je vais arrêter ça et berneuil
est venue un jour avec le livre de marc
saumaty de le lire et m'a dit si ça te
plait on fête le livre m'a plu et ils
ont là j'ai été tenté par l'aventuré je
crois pas qu'on puisse se dire oh c'est
dans une carrière maintenant je veux
faire que ça que s'il faut moi j'aime
bien laisser venir les choses et avoir
l'envi et souvent on me dit des fois que
je tourne pas avec des jeunes metteurs
en scène mais si elle m'a mené une chose
qui vous plaît beaucoup je dors mieux
régner de l'image que se font certains
metteurs en scène debout c'est sûr
c'est sûr on est toujours un peu victime
dune
d'une image et sans doute aussi souvent
des jeunes se disent pour moi si j'ai
trouvé belmondo et ne l'acceptera pas
parce qu'il ya toujours une légende au
cours d'une belette disons et
c'est pour je crois que je suis ouvert à
à tous le plus possible vous tournez
très souvent avec lorie vers nice et
autres ce qu'elle filme avec avid et
donc vous aimait beaucoup ce metteur en
scène pourquoi j'aime beaucoup pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que je
vais encore très bien avec lui
après j'ai toujours fait des très bons
films avec lui il en effet six balles et
les six ont été bien donc j'espère ce
septième sera bien est un signe à ce que
j'aime beaucoup il connaît très très
bien son métier les techniques parfait
et il parle pas c'est pas un amateur des
oreilles partout jour sur des bases très
solides et j'aime bien ça pour un acteur
c'est un repos une dernière question
posée à jean paul belmondo
son nom est arrivé au sommet de la
hiérarchie cinématographique
il est une vedette à part entière y at
il alors des raisons particulières pour
motiver son absence remarquée à la
télévision c'est un choix délibéré
comme avec je fais du
du cinéma ya aucune raison du deuil à la
télévision pour rien et je pense
d'autres bac la télévision je n'ai fait
que dans des interviews et pas trop
d'interviews non plus parce que c'est
pas bon qu'on vous voit tout le temps à
la télévision
on a beau dire il n'y a pas de guerre de
la division cinéma n'existe qu'en mai
elle est partie peu forcé ces deux arts
concurrents